this week the Trump administration
announced it will be suspending the
temporary protected status label for
immigrants from El Salvador basically no
journalist in America ever heard of this
till this week but all of a sudden
nothing this bad has ever happened
you've read that again and again so
here's what it's really about the move
affects about 200,000 Salvadorans who've
been allowed to live and work here since
2001 that was here an earthquake hit
their country the name of the program
temporary protected status alludes to
what its purpose was supposed to be it
was supposed to provide short-term
refuge from visitors from other
countries that were in short term
disorder that's not what happened that's
never what happens in fact it simply
become an illegal immigrant amnesty
program just like daca accepted targets
specific countries rather than people of
a specific age under TPS people are
protected from deportation and given
work permits even if they came to the US
illegally the excuse for this is not
surprisingly paper-thin the El Salvador
earthquake was bad very bad but the
notion they can't return home 17 years
later absurd the same goes for the
57,000 Hondurans who are still here
because of 1998 hurricane Mitch that was
20 years ago
or the 51,000 Haitians who are allowed
to stay here because of the 2010
earthquake in that country
this isn't about providing short-term
refuge its elites in Washington using a
legal loophole to let hundreds of
thousands of people come here
permanently without going through any of
the ordinary immigration channels now
you can tell that nobody ever expected
for them to return home because the
suggestion that they do return home is
being treated as a massive crisis for
some reason on Monday the New York Times
commented on quote the sense of dread
gripping employers in California Texas
and Virginia it's obvious why they feel
dread TPS effectively legalized hundreds
of thousands of low-wage workers in
those places and employers would rather
not have to pay high wages to actual
Americans politicians meanwhile are
upset the prospect of losing hundreds
and thousands of future save votes
that's what it's all about
anyone who tries to suggest otherwise is
lying to you or themselves